We're asked: Do the points
on the graph
below represent a function?
So in order for the points to
represent a function, for
every input into our function,
we can only get one value.
So if we look here, they've
graphed the point--it looks
like negative 1, 3, so that's
the point negative 1, 3.
So if we assume that this is our
x-axis and that is our f
of x axis, and I'm just assuming
it's a function, I
don't know whether it really
is just now, this point is
telling us that if you put
negative 1 into our function,
or that thing that might be
a function, or maybe our
relation, you'll get a 3 So
it's telling us that f of
negative 1 is equal to 3.
So far it could be a reasonable
function.
You give me negative 1 and
I will map it to 3.
Then they have if x is 2, then
our value is negative 2.
This is the point 2, negative
2, so that still seems
consistent with being
a function.
If you pass me 2, I will map
you or I will point you to
negative 2.
Seems fair enough.
Let's see this next
value here.
This is the point 3 comma
2 right there.
So once again, that says that,
look, if you give me 3 into my
function, into my black box,
I will output a 2.
Pretty reasonable.
No reason why these points
can't represent
a function so far.
Now, what about when we input
4 into the function?
Let me do this in magenta.
So what happens if I input
4 into my function?
So this is 4 right here.
Well, according to these points,
there's two points
that relate to 4 that
4 can be mapped to.
I could map it to the
point 4 comma 5.
So that says if you give me
a 4, I'll give you a 5.
But it also says if you give me
a 4, I could also give you
a negative 1 because that's
the point 4, negative 1 So
this is not a function.
It cannot be a function if for
some input into the function
you could give me two
different values.
And you can see that
right here.
And an easy test is to just
see, look, for one value I
have two points for
this relationship.
So this cannot be a function.
So this is not a function!
I'll put an exclamation mark.